hey y'all it's endercouch here and in
this taiyo teaser video we're gonna be
going over
um auto encoders i know i haven't really
been going over
the actual tidy tuesday weekly data sets
but i figured it'd be kind of more
interesting to go over neural networks
so i thought it'd be fun to make a video
on auto encoders um
so what are auto encoders well auto
encoders really just comprise off of
two models in an encoder which
essentially condenses
um the data into a specific amount of
features
given the nodes and then a decoder which
will basically
re-transform that condensed data into
the original
uh input and one way to think about
autoencoders
is about like image uh compression
where we're essentially compressing like
a 10 megabyte image into a two megabyte
image
so the actual underlying structure has
changed
but from a visual standpoint it looks
the same so you can see for this
original input to restructure input
and that's the uh the actual auto
encoder going to work and basically
recondensing it to this specific format
and then reprojecting it
to what it's supposed to look like in
its original format
um we can also look at it from i guess
the
the neural network architecture point of
view so we can see how we have our
inputs
uh we can decrease the inputs so it's um
condensing it and then we can see how
this is essentially like the bottleneck
or the minimum amount
of um how much we're essentially
condensing the the data
and we're reprojecting it um i'm also
going to be going over
uh for auto encoders is the credit card
fraud data set
i think when i think about auto encoders
you think about
uh anomaly detection or just embeddings
so we're gonna do these two examples
we're gonna do a um
anomaly detection problem and also an
embeddings problem
okay uh let's i'm going to open up a our
markdown file and it'll cause tidy
tuesday um auto
encoder so one thing that i will say is
i don't
have the data set in my repo you're
gonna have to go
on uh kaggle.com and download it
yourself because i didn't wanna
um basically mess with the storage in my
own uh personal repo
so we're gonna install we're gonna load
in three packages the tidyburst
keras and tidy models we're gonna read
in
our credit card data so it's credit i
have it named
credit card.csv
i'll say load in from kaggle.com
okay so if we look at our actual data
we can see we actually have um a decent
amount of features one thing that i'm
going to remove
is time i i think uh that's supposed to
be
something to do um it doesn't have a lot
to do with the actual um transaction so
we're gonna filter that out
and these um v features i think come
from like some type of principal
components analysis
um we also have the amount and also the
class that we're trying to predict
and our class is like uh zero and one
and let's see our average positive class
is less than a percent it's like one
tenth of a percent
so let's do some cleaning so i'll say
mutate
class is equal to if else class is equal
to one then we'll say it's fraud
else it's no fraud uh we'll create that
to a
factor um and we'll also
select minus time right
you can all see we have 284 000 uh
rows which is a lot of rows but it's
good for neural networks
and then we can see that we actually did
the thing correctly
so that's just some basic cleaning right
there we're gonna have to do some more
cleaning
but i want to first go over how we can
use auto encoders
um in our own problem to do to detect
anomaly detection
and one of the main ideas with an auto
encoder is we're trying to basically
teach it
what we should be expecting to see and
having it reproject it
so in this case what we're trying to do
is we have a highly imbalanced data set
of not non-fraudulent transactions and
fraudulent transactions
we have a lot of non-fraudulent actions
so we can basically teach the model
what a non-fraudulent action looks like
and then have it project
on all the actions so when it sees a
non-fraudulent action ideally since it's
seen
so many other non-fraudulent actions it
will be able to remap this
the data into the the actual original
data set
however since fragile action should be a
little bit different
it shouldn't actually it shouldn't be
able to um remap the fragile actions
in a correct space so
if it can't um reproject the data to its
original data set
then we can kind of confidently assume
that this transaction is a fraudulent
transaction
so how do we actually do that first
let's actually do some um data
cleaning so let's create our train and
test splits first
um all the set dot c is 42 i'll do a
tidy
split is equal to initial split df and
we'll stratify
i'm based off of class we'll create our
train data which will be a training
tidy split
and our test data which will be our
testing
tidy split what we also want to do is
split our trained data
into a fraudulent and non-fraudulent
data set so train data filter
class is equal to uh fraud
we also want to deselect our class
and then we also do a non-fraud df and
we'll do the same thing
but say it's not fraud let's say uh
exclamation point no fraud
okay ooh actually we could just
i'm gonna pop this right there we also
want to do
some um preprocessing to our data set so
if we look at our
trained data i'll do that
our train data if we look at the summary
of it
we can see that our min and max is all
over the place
and neural networks like values between
zero and one
so we could do some min max
normalization or we can do the tidy way
and use the range
um sep range um pre-processing so we'll
just do that so we'll do
tidy wreck recipe
we're trying to create a class a equals
train data
i'll say step uh range all
predictors boom like that
tidy wreck prep bake and we'll apply the
recipe to our train data
oh um
sorry about that i just threw that up
we'll apply that to our train data
uh where's our train to our train data
and we'll also apply it to our test data
so
test data test data
right and if we look at our actual train
data
we can see our values are between zero
and one
same with the test data
good cool
so now what we're going to do is split
our train data into fraudulent and
non-fraudulent transactions
and what we're going to try to do is
create a neural network to look at our
non-fraudulent actions
one thing that i will say is um once we
have these data frames or tables we want
to convert them into matrices so we're
just going to say as dot
matrix uh as dot
matrix cool
and now what we're gonna do is actually
define our auto encoder so auto encoder
and we'll say uh keras model sequential
and with our auto encoder we're gonna
have to
uh select our or define our layers so
our first layer will be a dense layer
our units will be 15. our activation
will be a railway action station and our
input dimensions
or input shape will be the amount of
features we have
in our uh matrix so we can say non
fraud df if we do our end call i believe
it's end call
and call non-fraud df we have 29 uh
columns and it's going to take those 29
columns or 29 nodes and take
out put them into uh
15 uh nodes
we're also going to do a a another layer
which will be a
five node layer okay
and then we'll also do a another layer
to go back up activation it goes really
and our last output layer will need to
be the amount of features we have
in our non-project df because we want to
basically remap
our data our features into the same
amount of features
cool so we have that we also will
do a um a compile
so with our compile oops usually we put
it
right there when we compile our
our model our loss function will be mean
squared error
and our optimizer will be atom
and we choose mean squared error because
uh it's essentially going to project
on the data uh our one transaction to
the same transaction
and we want those values to be basically
the same even though we condensed it
so we basically penalize it between how
off it is from the original value
cool so we have that and now what we can
do is actually
uh fit the encoder we'll say
auto encoder history and i'll say auto
encoder fit
and we'll give it our x and y's and
what's interesting about um auto
encoders is we're actually giving we're
actually going to give it
the same data sets so non-fraud df
epics for epochs is 100 batch size
um will be 32.
and then we'll do a validation split
is equal to 80 80 20. we're also going
to add some
options which will do our callback so
we'll just enable early stopping
and for early stopping we'll just say
that if we don't see
any um improvement in our validation
error then we'll just stop the neural
network early
and we're going to have to wait like 10
epics for it to do it
so we're running the neural network uh
it's going to take a little bit
hopefully it'll stop a little bit
earlier
so let's let it run and we can kind of
evaluate what it's actually doing you
can see the
um the loss the validation loss and it
should just
improve as it goes but then i'll
probably stop i mean like 20 or 30
epics
and also if you want to check it should
have the
we should have a little interactive
chart right here if we wanted to
actually look at that
so once we actually train our auto
encoder we're gonna actually predict it
based off of our other um our non-profit
and fraudulent data set and we'll see
how
um it's able to basically remap uh the
nonprofit
um features better than the fraudulent
features and that'll be good for
an actual model
okay so i'm actually gonna rewrite these
models so i'll just say oh we're gonna
use our
auto encoder we're going to give it our
non
raw df and we'll also say predict our
auto encoder and give it our fraud
df and we'll give those
our predictions so we'll say non-fraud
and then we'll say our our or was it our
fraud
see you can see how it's saying uh it
might stop the uh
training hopefully so it's ruptured
promise evaluation
okay so the model finished training i
actually i
i accidentally uh messed up the option
for callbacks so it went through the
entire
um iterations but that's fine
so we trained our model to look at our
non-fraudulent data sets i'm going to
predict based off
our fraudulent and non-fraudulent data
sets
cool so our non-fraud predictions are
actually in a matrix so if i do a
head we can see it's in matrix format
luckily r
again is a statistical programming
language
so to do matrix math is pretty easy
um what i want to basically calculate is
essentially the
the the sum or the total squared error
between each feature
or each uh um transaction so let's do
that
so this is our non-fraud um prediction
minus
our uh non-fraud actual
right
um and we'll square that and then we'll
just calculate the uh
the row sums of it so row sums
of the uh squared error
so we have that right there uh we can
call this a table
um and we'll say uh uh
total squared error
cool all right so we have a total
squared error for
all of our observations 213 000
observations
we'll do the same thing with our fraud
projections so
if we do that oops right there
little squared error now let's actually
look at the summary of it
of the errors for each um data set what
we can see here is our mean and median
is 0.01.02 and for the
actual fraudulent we can see it's a
little much higher
relative the to the actual um scale of
it
so we can see how we can actually detect
some type of error
in our model so now that we have this
one way to actually calculate or create
an anomaly detection model
is the uses errors as feature as
features
so let's actually do that so i'm going
to actually go back to our train data
um right here
our training data um i'm gonna
select minus class uh select minus class
and i'll do the same thing we're all
basically say i'll predict
our i'll use our auto encoder to predict
based off our trained data
right oops and we have to convert that
to a matrix
matrix and then we'll subtract that
to our train data select
minus class as dot matrix
right so this is our our our residual
we'll square it and then we'll calculate
the row
sums of the squared residual
and then we'll convert this to a table
to error
and that's our final
so that's our actual error right there
and then what we can do is our bind our
columns of our train
data and we'll select the class
and this will be our model data
so with our model data if we actually do
a group
by class and we'll do like a short
summarize it goes to mean
mean error we can see them the
fraudulent transactions have
a higher error because our auto includer
does not understand how to basically
reformat these
um fragile transactions and we'll
instead uh remap it to a
a non-fraudulent transaction and these
uh the difference between a
non-fraudulent approach on action
will cause a larger amount of error and
that's the big idea between
these uh models so let's actually just
create a logistic model so let's say
uh anomaly i'll say a nom
model because i don't know how to spell
anomaly model i'll say a logistic
reg um penalty is equal to zero
mixture is equal to zero and we'll fit
it to
class to error data is equal to model
data great so we have our
our anomaly model right here
um we can actually show let's see what
our actual model
um can fit in its in sample predictions
uh we'll just say bind column to model
data
select class and we'll say conf
matt truth is equal to class estimates
go to dot pred
right so it's not doing great
um but out of all the fragile
transactions it can detect 27 of them
um obviously if we do a logistic
regression i'm sure we can actually do a
little bit better so let's just do that
so baseline model
and we'll just say logistic rag to
was our train data
and let's see train data to that
okay so train data and we'll give it our
baseline model
our train data and let's see what it
looks like
so our logistic regression model did a
little bit better
or did actually a lot better than our
non-detection model but that's fine
because
generally um nowadays people don't
really use auto encoders for non-way
detection
but they used to be used for it and i
thought it'd be a kind of interesting
video to do
a actual video on it um we'll
we'll do our final test set predictions
so
let's do that um predict our auto
encoder and then our test data
select minus class and the as ass.matrix
and we'll just say we'll calculate the
squared error so let's say
write that oops so we'll just do that
and then we'll say
we'll do we'll calculate the total
square error
right here so row sums
of that
and then we'll hopefully that'll do that
yep and we'll say as
i will say table air is equal to that
and bind our our actual labels to
our uh
to our data set oops test
test data okay so that'll be our uh
eval set okay
and then we'll say predict our eval our
um what is it our
anomaly model
on our eval set
and we'll bind our columns to our eval
set
and we'll do our confusion matrix
i'll select the uh class
okay so we see our model did not do
very well let's do um
let's just evaluate on our test set just
to see how our baseline model
were to do on this problem
and we see it did a lot better and
that's why um
auto encoders are not that great for
analog detection but
what they are very good at is dealing
with
creating your own embeddings or your own
little um clusters
it'd be used for other analysis so we're
actually gonna do a part two on this
and deal with image data um
so let's actually do that um let's
create let's load in the
the mnist data set so let's say mnist
um was it data
keras uh mnist dataset mnist
okay so we have that um
what else can we do so and then we can
um do our
x our let's say train x which will be
our mnist mnist
uh df was it train
x and we'll say train y which will be
our
labels i'll say a train now we'll say
train y so this is
that'll be our labels for our data set
train y and we'll do a
test x um
which will be our testing um labels and
then
our test y which will be the
i mean yeah test test label so the x
will be the actual
um pixels and the y will be the actual
labels
so we have it with split in our training
test sets
okay we'll do that and one thing that
we'll
also have to do is normalize it so our
test x
will be our
sorry about that our test x will be um
um we'll be uh
uh formatted so if we look at our our
test our train
x um we're gonna have to do some
uh pre-processing or actually we'll do a
maybe a summary
so 255. so if we do train x divided by
255 and then we do a summary
we have we assigned a min max
normalization
cool so let's do that so our train x
is equal to that test
x is equal to test x
test x is divided by 255.
um if we also look at our our data set
our images we can see that in 6 60
000 images 20 by 28 pixels we actually
want to reshape these pixels so
because we're not doing any
convolutional neural networks we're just
doing a densely
neural network we need to flatten this
so we're just going to
reshape these uh um these images
or these um matrices so we'll give it
our train x
our dimension we'll just say n row
so train x and we'll just say 28 by 28
so essentially we're going to be convert
converting this square
into a long uh line
and we'll do the same thing for a test
so
we're saying like this is how many rows
boom
if we look at our uh variables we can
see that we basically converted these um
squares into a long little line
uh that's 28 by 28 so it's just
re-changing it
cool so now let's actually make an image
auto encoder
and it's literally the same thing for
any other auto
encoder so we're going to
define our sequential model and then
we'll start doing our
um layers we'll start initiating our
later so layer
dense um in this case since we have 228
by 28
so 784 we'll we're not going to use 15
i'm actually going to use like 256.
so your units equals 256. activation
is relu um
and then what else oh yeah input
shape is equal to end call train
x actually let's see here 28 by 28 um
we could do 512 actually i'll do 5 12.
cool and then i'll do another layer
in this case i'll just do 256
activation is equal to relu
a final layer which will be
in this case let's just do eight because
i have an idea of how to show
on these layer embeddings so let's say
eight
so we're essentially going to use these
eight um
um we're essentially using condensing
these um 784 features into eight
features
um activation is equal to a regular
activation again
and then we'll just copy and paste this
this other stuff
obviously we have to remove this input
shape
and then our layer dense output
will be the number of columns
in our actual data or the number of
features interactional data
great so now we have that uh we can do
our image encoder
compile our loss again will still be
mean squared
error and our optimizer
will be atom okay
um we can also show this summary of the
neural network so
summary of autoencoder we have this many
layers we can see how we have our little
dents layer right there one thing that
i'm actually going to
do is actually rename it so i'll say
name is equal to embedding
because in this case we're actually not
going to do any anomaly detection
we're going to use a neural network to
basically use it to create
a layer embeddings or to basically
condense our features into
our defined amount of features in this
case eight
so once once i have the name for it i'll
just always call it embedding
okay sorry about that i actually um
exited the uh
the obs recorder but we're gonna
actually train up our
image auto encoder so image history
history we'll do our image
encoder we'll fit it our x will be
our train x our y will be our
all input epics will be 50 our batch
size will be
120 a validation splits
will be 80 20.
and i'm not going to mess up the
callbacks so i'll say callbacks
is equal to call back early stopping
uh patience is equal to we'll do
five um epix
and epix batch size
train x what did i do
oh there you go go there
um oh wow i forgot my commas
okay so now we're gonna train up our
neural network
so we're essentially doing the same
thing as our auto encoder
but instead of actually using the the
error rates in
our outputs what we're going to do is
actually
take the outputs from one of our layers
we're going to let this run and i'll
probably get back to you after this
model finishes fitting itself
okay the model um finished fitting and
now we can actually look at it
so with our image encoder we have a auto
encoder
like our previous state but what we
actually want to do is extract the
outputs
from this layer only we will essentially
output
from our given um 28 was it 28
times 28 our 784
feature data set we can basically
condense it to eight
features and the way to do it is we're
actually going to create a separate
model
called the image embedding embedded
we'll say embeddings model
and what we have to say is keras model
and our keras model has our inputs and
outputs
in this case our inputs will be the same
inputs
used from our original encoder let's say
input
but our output
oops outputs our outputs will be
our image encoders
um we'll have to retrieve the layer from
our
um image encoder model
and what we already know is we named it
embedding
so embedding and then with this layer
since it's essentially extracting the
layer
from the model right
we can just say we want the uh was it
output cool and now if we actually look
at our
embeddings model
we can see it's the same image encoder
model but it's essentially chopped
where you have the output as our
embedding um
layer so what is what does this mean
well we can actually predict
um using our embeddings model so we'll
do that and we'll just
predict it based off our x our train
x right because this is the the data
that we originally trained it with
okay and you can see we have eight
embeddings
um we can convert this to a table so as
tibble
and then we can also add the label so
say bind columns
train y and we'll say table
labels is equal to train y
okay and we can see how we have our zero
through nine
digits and we'll call this our model
data actually i want to mutate something
so i'll say mutate
labels is equal to as factor wait
labels and this will be our image
model data so essentially we condense
784 features into
eight uh embedding features with our
label data
and one thing that's kind of cool is we
can actually train a multinomial
logistic regression to do some image um
computer image
or computer vision modeling so let's do
that so let's create a
multinomial we'll say image
model and we'll say multi nomial reg
our mode will be mode is equal to
classific oops mode is equal to
classification
cost classification
penalty is zero mixture is zero
and we'll fit it in our labels
data is equal to image model
data okay and now let's actually do our
eval image so we'll say predict our
embeddings model
our image or our embeddings model
with our train our test
data set which will be our test x
and then we'll predict our image predict
our image model given our eval
embeddings
oops and then we had to say uh eval
image
and we'll say it was as a
as a typical and then let's bind our
columns
to our um
labels is equal to uh was it
uh oh was it a
test why we have our labels
and then we do our confusion matrix
so truth is equal to labels
estimate is equal to class
and have to do a labels
equal to as dot factor
labels
uh what's here
right s
estimate
and then we do our confusion matrix
truth is equal to
labels estimate is good.pred
class and we can see how our
basic logistic regression did very well
with a multi-class classification
problem
we essentially reduced 784 features into
eight
um very high information features and we
got some nice predictive power from it
which is one of the good things about
auto encoders is we
essentially generate and reduce some
feature reduction using neural networks
so i know this is a pretty information
packed video but
i hope it informed you guys and i'll see
you guys next week and tidy on